hey everyone its Sally but you can go so
Mandor if you want to so for a long time
now I have been waiting for someone to
do a Godzilla movie with a new
technology we have now and finally
they're doing it so I know I can even
like contain my excitement right now
I've heard that the trailer is awesome
so I don't even know what to expect I've
already seen a lot of really cool
trailers so I'm hoping this one will
blow me away more than any other one oh
[Music]
my god
Zilla someone tweet that so it becomes a
thing and I don't look like an idiot
let's just watch it because I'm too
excited for this the Walking Dead is
that right that's Bryan Cranston this is
voice Heisenberg listening
it is gonna send us back to the Stone
Age
how many natural disasters is this thing
gonna cause I come
oh my god no you can't do it
everyone's gonna die
is that a ribcage
and not the other way around
oh my god but I don't I have no words I
don't even know what to say to be quite
honest that looked so badass and the
fact that they kept Godzilla you know
just the way he looked the fact they
kept that a mystery that the whole
entire thing was brilliant
again remind me of that worm guy and so
involved it like intact the whole entire
city all seriousness I'm so excited I
didn't know Bryan Cranston was in this
movie and now it makes it ten times
better just because of Bryan freakin
Cranston oh my goodness I haven't been
this excited for a movie in a very long
time probably the first Hobbit or
something I mean this is just this seems
like it'll be so epic anyway thank you
so much for watching be sure to check
out this channel like all the rest of
the videos subscribe to Ryan and Jerry
cuz they're awesome guys and we have a
lot more things in store for this
channel so you have to stay tuned and
just check out my channel because Ryan
and erm use me and it's really weird and
really funny and the second part of that
interview comes out this week I don't
even know what to do right now so I'm
going to say goodbye and I'll see you
guys later